hey everyone jake here we're going to
have a lot of destiny 2 content in the
near future so if you want to stay up to
date make sure to subscribe to our
channel
thank you and enjoy
if there's a single word to describe
destiny 2 it's disruption
in the sequel to bungie's popular shared
world shooter the guardians of earth
have finally met their match with a new
villain who's got his eyes on the
traveler
with their powers stripped away and all
their gear destroyed our heroes are
pushed back to square one and they have
to relearn what it means to be a true
guardian of the light
is mine
though it'll be sad to see our valuable
exotics fade into the ether this turns
out to be a blessing as our next
adventure for our characters will bring
new challenges new rewards and an even
greater feeling of satisfaction when
accomplishing the next big battle
though the general grind in destiny 2 is
the same there are a number of big
differences this time around and
gamespot is here to let you know
some of the bigger changes since the
last game's adventure
[Music]
while destiny 1's narrative was
undoubtedly built on a universe with a
vast history and a lot of thought put
into it it often struggled with
conveying those ideas
opting for a more fragmented and
episodic take on its storytelling with
the sequel bungie has gone with a
traditional approach for a more
consistent narrative
gradually fleshing out key characters in
locales and giving them the moments they
deserve
impressing uk is the easiest thing i'll
do all day
teasing the taking king mission outbound
signal the main antagonist in destiny 2
is cabal emperor dominus gaul
unlike the first game which struggled to
figure out exactly what the darkness was
the warlord behind the red legion is a
tangible character with additional story
beats revealing why he came to earth to
find the traveler and what his plans are
with its power
if you're a returning guardian this
story will essentially pick up where you
left off after rise of iron
destiny went through several loot
overhauls over its first year and beyond
making great strides in the taking king
expansion before it found a sense of
equilibrium
in destiny 2 the loot system has been
revised a bit more
focusing more on keeping players in the
action better gear comes in a more
steady stream
and generally won't come encrypted
enabling guardians to stay powered up
while preventing the hassle of dragging
encrypted engrams to the crypt arc
moreover random roles for weapons and
armor have been dropped ditching the
frustration of finding rare weapons with
lousy perks
there are also more opportunities and
ways to find new gear with high profile
targets that drop loot cases
the lost sectors and finishing tasks for
each planet's faction to yield rewards
when unlocking loot you'll no longer
have to undergo bizarre rituals to
ensure that you get the best
outcome overall gear power in your
entire inventory will be factored in
making switching over to your most
powerful gear unnecessary
furthermore encrypted engrams are more
rare and allowing a maximum of 10
encrypted engrams to be held at any
given time
when it comes to exploration destiny 2
will make much better use of your time
in the open areas on each planet
while the drop destiny 1 was about the
exploration of planets and interstellar
locales
it often felt limited in scope with its
focus of repeating daily missions and
patrols
with places like the european dead zone
the largest map in a destiny game
the new diversions and opportunities
make the various locations feel much
more fleshed out
with public quests and other activities
shown clearly on the map along with
timers for upcoming events and rally
flags to summon guardians there's much
less busy work when trying to figure out
what to do
next while there's still plenty of
patrol and story missions taking you
around various game worlds the new
adventure missions are more directed
quests given out by allies in the field
focusing on the history of the planet
they'll send you to the more obscure and
bizarre reaches of the world while
learning more of the setting and the
characters that inhabit it
is that a sack full of shanks
what do you think they're going to do
with all that tech can you make a big
shank from a bunch of little shanks
these missions offer a nice break from
the more epic and set-piece-focused
story missions and the plain objectives
of patrols while also getting to learn
more about the allies that still inhabit
the spaces
[Music]
though the original game had various
shaders ships sparrows and unique pieces
of class armor to unlock it felt
rudimentary
making the sight of a similar guardian a
common occurrence
the sequel will offer more variation and
change up the number of systems that
made the accessories and options feel
constrained
on top of this the eververse will have
more use aside from being the designated
microtransaction
shop with the new bright engrams these
special lootcases yield a variety of
standard and cosmetic gameplay items
including
shaders which are now consumables
applied to single pieces of gear and
brand new ships for your guardian
found throughout the quests and after
reaching level 20 with each level up
after granting a new engram
these offer more dedicated ways to
acquire new accessories
along with new items called auras a
dedicated option for visual effects such
as flames and other odd designs applied
to your characters cosmetics now come in
a variety of
tiers we acquired an exotic ranked emote
from a bright engram which allowed the
guardian to channel their powers to
express themselves in some odd and
amusing
ways there are ways to customize your
loadouts as well
in addition to the various shaders new
weapons mods can be found and applied to
your weapons
in addition to this is the return of
infusing which is more viable than it is
in the previous game
[Music]
while the destiny community are
resilient for keeping up with the game
there were a distinct lack of systems to
support them in the long run
several websites were created by fans to
fill in the gap for tracking public
events
clan support and several looking for
group databases
bungie have now made great strides with
integrating these features into the game
matchmaking is now available for
high-end content for solo players who
will be paired up with clans and other
fire teams looking for members
there is now also dedicated clan support
giving players the chance to create a
group on bungie's official site and
invite members of the community to join
along with creating unique clan banners
and having clan dedicated chats and
forums a clan will also work together to
gain unique clan rewards and bonuses
through their journey which are
cumulatively added up among members
these rewards come in many different
forms such as unique emblems and auras
but will constantly change and shift
depending on the weekly refresh
for those returning destiny 2 will be an
experience that is familiar but also
more refined
and detailed in its approach to building
up a unique character
and for those coming in fresh bungie's
sequel looks to offer a stunning
and broad game world to explore along
with tons of monsters to shoot and loot
to find
this shared world shooter has a lot on
display and after years of work it's
ready to show off what it can do in its
second outing
if you're craving more destiny 2 content
be on the lookout for our upcoming show
destiny's children where our us and uk
teams will take the reins on long plays
and live streams for destiny 2.
thank you for watching
[Music]
this is great anyone want a hug no hugs